y
[Música]
se cumple un año desde que la
organización mundial de la salud declaró
la pandemia de kobe 19 el mundo acumula
118 millones de casos y 2 millones y
medio de fallecimientos con las
esperanzas puestas en la vacunación y
con un nuevo estilo de vida que incluyen
mascarillas como artículo de primera
necesidad y distancia social
japón conmemora 10 años del accidente
nuclear de fukushima oraciones y
protestas hicieron parte de los
homenajes a las miles de víctimas
fatales del terremoto de magnitud 9 y
posterior tsunami que destruyó ciudades
y liberó contaminación radioactiva de la
planta de daikin aún hoy el pueblo nipón
e intenta recuperarse
y el congreso de eeuu aprobó finalmente
el paquete de rescate fiscal por 1,9
billones de dólares para salvar la
economía frente a la pandemia es la
primera victoria legislativa del
presidente joe biden y uno de los planes
más ambiciosos de la historia del país
con pagos de 1400 dólares a la mayoría
de ciudadanos tenemos reporte
una feliz mañana mi nombre es ángela
gómez y aquí comienzan las noticias de
france 24 iniciamos el informativo con
kobe 19 este 11 de marzo se cumple un
año desde que la organización mundial de
la salud declaró que la propagación del
virus se convirtió en pandemia aquel día
el mundo registrado a 118 mil casos
confirmados y 4200 fallecimientos en 114
países un año después nos acercamos a
los 118 millones de casos y ya superamos
2 millones y medio de muertes en 192
naciones
a continuación luís muñoz o nos hace un
repaso de este primer año difícil de
olvidar de pandemia mundial era el 11 de
marzo de 2020 así estaban las
principales calles de roma a la capital
de italia olas del epicentro del cob y
19 en wuhan china los supermercados no
daban abasto y la población temía que se
acabase en las existencias de papel
higiénico no había mascarillas que se
reservaban para el personal de salud
erigidos en héroes involuntarios las
escuelas cerraban
y las bolsas se desplomaban el virus
llegaba a américa latina' ese dia panamá
y bolivia declararon sus primeros casos
los eeuu prohibía viajes con europa y la
población mundial quedaba aislada en su
territorio y muchas personas en su
propia casa ese 11 de marzo la
organización mundial de la salud
declaraba la pandemia mundial
estamos profundamente preocupados tanto
por los alarmantes niveles de
propagación y gravedad como por los
alarmantes niveles de inacción levels of
in action
we are there for me por lo tanto hemos
evaluado que el commit 19 se puede
caracterizar como una pandemia
caracteres y pandémica países de todo el
mundo ordenaban restricciones para dos
semanas las más largas de nuestras vidas
un año después el virus sigue activo con
alrededor de 118 millones de casos y más
de 2 millones y medio de fallecidos
primero fue china luego italia-españa
nueva york' y brasil el kobe 19 saturaba
hospitales de todo el mundo para después
reaparecer con fuerza en virulentas
nuevas olas y variantes los efectos del
coronavirus han llevado a las economías
a la peor crisis en décadas esto ha
derivado en protestas corrupción pobreza
y también en el surgimiento de un
negacionismo que ha agravado el curso de
la pandemia sin embargo también han
surgido olas de solidaridad que culminan
en una cooperación mundial histórica con
la que se ha conseguido desarrollar
vacunas en tiempo récord una señal de
esperanza para que el fin de la pandemia
cada día más cerca en un año imposible
de olvidar en brasil la pandemia está en
su peor momento este miércoles se
alcanzó de nuevo una cifra récord de
muertes por el virus más de 2.200
personas perdieron la vida la nación
latinoamericana es la tercera del mundo
con más contagios su sistema de salud
está al borde del colapso
la vacunación avanzan lentamente y los
decesos totales ellas son más de 270.000
los contagiados acumulados son 11,2
millones
cambio de tema un momento de silencio
dio paso al décimo aniversario del
desastre nuclear de fukushima en tokio
el emperador naruhito y su esposa
honraron a las más de 19 mil víctimas
del triple desastre que comenzó con un
terremoto de magnitud 9 seguido por un
tsunami y por el colapso de la planta
nuclear de daiichi en los discursos
oficiales se recordó la destrucción de
ciudades y la devastación de fukushima
con varias poblaciones de que hoy
todavía permanecen inhabitables el
accidente nuclear es considerado el más
grande desde chernóbil
álvaro cordero nos amplia
el 11 de marzo de 2011 un terremoto
sacudió de forma violenta la costa
pacífica de japón su potencia que llegó
a los 9,1 grados en la escala de richter
provocó un gran tsunami que arrasó con
prácticamente todo el litoral y mató a
más de 19 mil personas miles de
ciudadanos perdieron todo y se vieron
obligados a desplazarse aunque ya no
haya terremotos todavía sigo sintiendo
que la tierra tiembla es aterrador
pero lo más grave sucedió en la central
nuclear de fukushima daichi cuyas
instalaciones estaban al borde del mar y
fueron afectadas por el oleaje la falta
de un muro de contención hizo que el
agua inundara una gran parte y que el
sistema de seguridad fallara esto generó
una fusión nuclear parcial en tres
reactores explosiones de hidrógeno y
fugas radioactivas muy elevadas se
estima que unas 160 mil personas
tuvieron que huir de sus poblaciones
debido a la radiación un desastre del
que se acusó a la empresa tepco sakae y
nóminas aman y nos gustaría disculparnos
desde el fondo de mi corazón por haber
causado tantos problemas y dolor a tanta
gente y en la sociedad en general
a pesar de los graves cargos de
negligencia que se imputaron a sus tres
ex directivos todos salieron absueltos
en 2019 diez años después siguen las
tareas de reconstrucción de la zona que
se prolongarán hasta 2031 aunque el
gobierno ha permitido regresar a muchas
zonas más de 36.000 personas siguen
fuera de sus hogares y existe un gran
miedo a volver y sufrir daños por la
radiación todavía presente en algunos
lugares
después de semanas de debates el
congreso estadounidense finalmente
aprobó el plan de estímulo económico
propuesto por el presidente joe biden
por valor de 19 billones de dólares y
que pretende sanar la depresión
económica provocada por la pandemia el
plan de rescate es la primera gran
victoria legislativa para el presidente
vamos a washington con nuestro
corresponsal de cristóbal vázquez
cristóbal buenos días y que incluye este
millonario estímulo financiero una de
las promesas de campaña de bailén
pues uno de los puntos uno de las ayudas
financieras que incluye este plan de
estímulo económico de 19 millones de
dólares son los cheques este será la
tercera vez que los estadounidenses
reciben cheque durante este año de
pandemia el cheque será de 1.400 dólares
a las personas que reciban ingresos
menores a 80 mil dólares al año y a los
hogares que reciban conjuntamente
ingresos menores de 160 mil dólares al
año los desempleados tendrán seguirán
teniendo ayudas semanales será la ayuda
de 300 dólares semanales esta ayuda se
acaba este fin de semana y por eso los
demócratas querían asegurarse de que
pasara esta ayuda en el congreso antes
de que los desempleados se quedaran sin
ayuda esta ayuda a los desempleados irá
hasta el 6 de septiembre también ahora
350.000 millones de dólares en ayudas a
gobiernos locales y estatales esta ayuda
también pues se le suma la el dinero que
va destinado a la vacunación y también a
ayudarle a los estadounidenses a pagar
renta y a las familias que tienen recién
nacidos y cristóbal esta noche el
presidente joe biden dará un discurso a
la nación que se prevé de su alocución
si el discurso se prevé que dure 20
minutos será a las 8 de la noche hora de
washington y se centrará en cómo
encontrarle una salida a la pandemia se
conmemorará y se recordara alavesa más
de 525 mil muertes de pandemia acá en
eeuu y el presidente hará una hoja de
ruta una baja de ruta de cómo será la
final de la pandemia en eeuu resaltará
además lo que ha hecho en sus primeros
50 días de gobierno sobre todo en el
esfuerzo que ha hecho de vacunación y
pues hay que resaltar que el presidente
joe biden tiene en este momento cerca de
un 60% de aprobación así que pues hará
énfasis en eso en lo que ha hecho de
positivo de cara a la pandemia para
poder que eeuu vuelva a la normalidad
cristóbal gracias por su reporte
continuamos atentos al desarrollo de las
noticias de esta mañana eso es todo por
el momento recuerde que puede seguirnos
también en francia- y 24 punto coma con
actualizaciones cada hora de nuestros
periodistas siga con nosotros buenos
días
[Música]